all right so we're going to talk about
Jupiter and how it the kind of
multi-language nature of Jupiter and how
how Jupiter evolved out of ipython and
why jupiter is no longer called ipython
notebooks and how it's even though we're
at PI data and we feel very much at home
at PI data with all the notebook demos
and everything that we're on the Jupiter
side we're not we're not just about
Python that we want to enable people to
do the cool stuff we've been doing an
eye Python in a variety of languages so
to start out we've got just a little bit
of architecture of how this stuff works
of we have ipython which started out as
you know just better interactive Python
in the shell you got Python execution
and then input and output in a terminal
and then as a part of building things
like the notebook we had it we added
essentially a protocol for how you get
input and output from the Python
execution to the person so we we
abstracted rather than talking directly
to the terminal from Python code we
abstracted a bit of how do we ask to run
code and then how do we communicate the
outputs that are the result from that
code and communicate that to the person
running the code so what and this is
this is always a source of confusion
what's I - what's Jupiter we get you
know we get these questions all the time
of wait is that actually a night Python
issue is it a Jupiter issue what repo do
I need to report this bug on you know
who's which project is responsible for
this feature that's not working properly
or that's amazing that I want to help
out with so ipython which is the eye is
for interactive it's an abbreviation
which is why we capitalized the I we
always capitalized the ini Python it is
is not an Apple product it's just
interactive Python regular abbreviation
and it provides you know better
interactive Python
extensions to the language like magics
you know the kind of more Shelley syntax
for LS you know CD the time at magic
adds better completion introspection you
know showing you doc strings all these
things these are these are ipython
features for interacting with the Python
language and Jupiter is all the stuff
that we use the generic and that we use
to talk to to Python so we've got this
messaging protocol that we use to say
okay I'm I want you to run some code I
want you to display some output okay
here's the output I know how to display
it it's also this document format so all
these notebook presentations that we've
seen are these notebook JSON documents
then encapsulate the input the output
markdown and and a bunch of metadata so
we store things like slide transitions
for the the nice live notebook demos
that we've seen here those are stored in
metadata on on the cells that that we
use to kind of take a notebook and then
render it as a reveal.js presentation
for instance and then we've also got
things like the notebook application
when you're running the notebook that's
an application for building for running
code viewing things and actually
producing the notebook documents and
then we've got a variety of tools for
either working with the notebook
document format like indie convert which
is our tool that says okay you've got a
Jason document that's got output inputs
and outputs and I want to plug that into
my publication pipeline whether that's a
blog that wants markdown or whether
that's your Sphinx documentation you
want to write your string stocks as a
notebook or you've got you know you want
to write an academic paper and you want
to generate some la tech or PDFs for for
more traditional publication pipeline
and then we've also got services around
it around notebooks and enbe convert so
we've got NB viewer where you can go to
find you know you can probably publish
any raw notebook anywhere on the
Internet and then you can click a link
and it will render that as an HTML page
so that anybody can actually see the
nice you know rendered input and output
of your notebook without having to have
the kind of authoring software that that
you use to make it and then we've got
tools surrounding deploying notebook so
Jupiter hub is a multi-user server that
we use for hosting classes or research
groups so you can as as a user you can
log in and get your own server on those
resources without and helping sysadmin
deploy that without having to open a
bunch of ports its each notebook server
listens on its own port jupiter hub puts
up a proxy so that you only need to have
one regular vanilla web server and then
everything happens behind the scenes in
terms of giving each user their own
server to work on and all the stuff
that's Jupiter specific that's you know
deploying notebook servers the notebook
document format the messaging protocol
there's actually nothing python specific
about any of these things that you know
if when you're executing it's here's
some code you need to say what language
it is for the highlighting but it
doesn't there's nothing python about you
know here's a string of text run it
produce some output and similarly the
outputs are here is a representation of
some output there's nothing it doesn't
matter what you know what language the
code was that ran it so a bit about the
protocol that we use we use a bunch of
sockets from a networking library called
0 mq where the kernel which is what we
call the process where code runs has a
collection of sockets that listen for
particular kinds of messages and then
you can connect clients to those sockets
you can connect a full client like we
use in the notebook that connects to all
the different sockets for gathering
output for requesting execution and for
responding to Ryan put requests
or you can actually you can connect
services to a kernel that actually
provide less than all that functionality
so you can you can write a little
service that just listens to the output
publication and that just logs all the
outputs produced or actually logs all
the execution all the code that somebody
asked to run so you can actually have
services sitting next to a notebook that
is doing you know saying oh somebody
asked this code to run on this kernel so
how are these messages look like so 0 mq
is kind of the transport we use it's a
socket library that gives us some some
nice features but to format at a high
level is really a just a Python
dictionary with there's a header with
some information about the message and
then there's a body that's like what
what is the content of the message the
ear that you're trying to send so when
you type in a notebook print hello world
the browser builds a message with a type
execute request so you're you're
requesting that some code be executed
and then the body of that message is has
some code and that code is print hello
world right so you're just i've typed
some text in a box and i've said hey
colonel please do whatever you think
this text means and so there's no
knowledge in the front end of what the
what the code means and this has
advantages and disadvantages the
advantage is that we've got this super
generic protocol that anybody can
implement there are disadvantages in
that you can't it actually makes it
harder for us to do kind of clever
language inference things in the front
end so once you've submitted this
execution then you get a reply that says
ok it worked you know here's the prompt
number that you got that we put in the
little in and out boxes and if it didn't
work you'll get a trace back and that
comes back on the same the same socket
so you submitted a request and you get a
reply straight back
and there's a side channel that we call
IO pub where outputs and things happen
these happen on a different socket
that's a 0 mq publisher socket so it's
actually broadcast to everything that's
connected to the kernel they all get the
same outputs and one of the common ones
is a display data message so what
display data is this is the the rich
math message we use for I've got
something that I want you to put I want
you to show and in addition to the kind
of plain text that we've got in a
terminal say this this object actually
has multiple representations I know the
simple text representations that in
Python we just call a wrapper but in
this case it's also got an SVG implement
it an SVG representation or a la tech
representation or a PNG representation
and then it sends those is what we call
a mind bundle so it's a it's a
dictionary keyed by mime type saying
these are all representations of the
same object and then the front end says
I like the you know I I understand text
I can always display text I don't think
we have any friends that can't display
text but I really like SVG's so if
there's an SVG I'm gonna pick that
instead of text and different front ends
have different display priorities that
say you know I technically can do this
one of the interesting examples is the
QT console which is another front-end
for the same Jupiter kernels it
understands many formats but some of
them it doesn't implement very well and
so it actually has a different display
priority than the interactive notebook
because certain display types actually
behave better than others and then you
can also have you can use this mind
bundle format for things like NB convert
so let's say you're you want to produce
a PDF with la tech often what can be
useful is vector formats like PDF
figure those don't display very well in
the live notebook but PNG is don't look
very nice in a lot tech PDF so what do
you do you can in ipython say matplotlib
when you publish a figure give me both
the PNG and the PDF and the live
notebook is gonna say oh I got a PNG I
like those I'm gonna display that and
then you can when you go through and be
convert to lot tech this is AHA there's
a PDF version of this figure I'm gonna
use that instead of the PNG so you get a
nice vector a nice vector figure in your
lot like PDF and then a nice high DPI
raster figure in live notebook and you
get all of these from the my Mundell
representation and various message types
that we've got so you've got execute
request and reply that's the standard
kind of read eval loop that we have
execute input this is something that
every time every time you execute a
message the kernel actually broadcasts
hey everybody who's listening I'm about
to run this code and we've got display
data which we use for representing rich
rich outputs stream messages these are
what you get for when you type print
when you write to standard in stand it
out these are just plain terminal texts
and so these get processed through you
know ANSI escapes and stuff like that
and then error messages which have trace
backs and the next acute result is
here's here's the result of the
execution status messages these are if
you ever seen the little circle that's
filled or or empty these are how the
kernel communicates I'm doing some work
says I'm busy now and then when it
finishes it says I'm idle so you get a
little indicator of when your kernel is
available for doing work and then we've
got additional messages like inspect
request and so this is what happens when
in if you're in an I Python notebook and
ipython notebook is still a meaningful
term it means you've got a Jupiter
notebook and you're running the ipython
kernel so if you type of
then you hit shift tab you get this
little pop-up of the docstring saying
you know what you know show me something
where as far as Jupiter is concerned
it's saying show me some information
about kind of where in the code the
cursor is currently and then we've got
complete requests you know these are
your standard you hit tab to complete
and it says it asks the kernel you know
what what symbols might I want to add
here and then we've got a document
describing all the messages in detail
this is a very long detailed document
that it should be should be at least you
know the reference that you need for if
you want to write your own kernel this
is this is where you start this is this
is the protocol that you want to
implement this is what a message looks
like and we've got all the different
different categories of messages and the
wire format and all these things heavily
documented for going out and building
your own kernel and people have done
this there are currently over 50 kernels
that have been written I was sitting
with David pew a little bit apparently
there are like five scholar kernels not
entirely sure I guess nobody's happy
with whatever anybody else is doing in
in that community but they're but there
are lots of kernels and the really
important thing here is that we the the
Jupiter and ipython developers are major
contributors to very very few of them
that our main contribution is you know
we're working on the UI we've got this
protocol and then people say oh I want
to you know and Ruby on ski says I want
you know I want to use this notebook in
Haskell and so he wrote you know we
wrote the kernel side in Haskell and now
we've got this wonderful Haskell
notebook and the same thing has happened
in the julia community and thomas
started the our kernel and that's
getting picked up and
and sage uses it and there's Erlang
there's go there's C++ even so there's
in terms of writing your own kernel so
let's say there you know you you've got
a project whether it's a you know a DSL
that you're working on that you know you
use in your company or you've got some
language that isn't supported or you
merely want to do something I Python
like you want to extend the language and
kind of give you know modify the
execution semantics at things like
magics to the language of your of your
choice there's there's three kinds of of
kernel the canonical you know the
first-class kernel is what we call a
native kernel where the entire kernel
machinery is written in the language of
the kernel and that's what ipython is
that's what julia is that's what the our
kernel is so the julia kernel is a julia
package that's written all and julia
that implements the wire protocol and
messaging protocol for for executing
code and the same is true in ipython and
our but the ipython package actually has
taken this is work that that thomas
mostly did has taken the it's
implementation of the message protocol
and kind of put that in a in a simple
base class and so what you can do is
write what we call a wrapper kernel and
so we've got a Python object that
implements the the message protocol and
then it's this kernel class defines a
few methods there like do execute do you
know completion and all you need to do
is subclass that and define those one
two or three methods and then you've got
a kernel if you know how to with a
Python API call run code in your
language you can use that to get
yourself quickly up and running with a
with the kernel in your language or your
you know your particular application and
we've got a nice document describing you
know going through basically an entire
example of
this is in fact a completely working
kernel that does execution where the
execution semantics are defined as
printing the code that you typed now you
can the execution semantics are totally
arbitrary you can say do whatever you
want with that with that text it could
be you know rendering restructured text
to HTML it could be you know anything
that's text input and any number of
outputs you can write as a kernel and
this wrapper kernel machinery makes it
makes it easy to to to write more and
more of these
and then the last piece that we also
ship is what we call a replica Knoll so
this is taking the rapper the rapper
Colonel machinery but wrapping a colonel
that already has its own terminal
terminal repple so like take bash or
recently I worked on a colonel for a
interactive C++ interpreter called Kling
that has its own terminal interpreter
for if you wanted to type C++ at the
terminal interactively that's something
you can technically do and so I wrote a
wrapper around around that and you know
this is the most limited kind of kernel
but sometimes it's all you've got if
it's the only way you you have the only
API you have for evaluating code in your
language is instantiating dead languages
own existing repple you can use this to
to to bootstrap and get that into the
into the notebook and the reference
example of this is the bash kernel which
essentially it's a bash interpreter
sends a code gets and gets standard and
sent out and stuff like that
the normally when you have one of these
replicas you don't get you only get
plain terminal output you don't get the
rich mime type output bash is a peculiar
exception to this in that there's the
bash kernel provides a fancy mechanism
for actually displaying images and
things that I won't go ahead how that
works but it's kind of a cool tool and
so taking an example of things like this
of I wrote that that toy wrapper for
Kling the C++ interpreter just during a
break at a write the docs conference in
Portland and I wrote that as a rep arap
err of just I can you know you've got an
interpreter I can wrap it here it is
it's a toy for interactive C++ it turns
out people at CERN use this the people
who made clang actually use this for
actually doing analysis of the sign
the results from their accelerators so
they actually you know they're invested
in Kling and they have people who want
to use it in the notebook so in December
Thomas and I went to CERN to talk about
clean Colonel and Jupiter have that many
other things and one of the things we
worked on was actually promoting the
clink colonel from this repple wrapper
to actually adding api's to cling itself
so that we could move cling over to
being kind of a regular colonel where
we're actually calling python CEAP eyes
so we're saying instantiating a klingon
interpreter in the current process and
then passing code for it to execute and
capturing output in a more natural way
and the success of this is you know went
from a toy that I wrote you know on a
lunch break at a conference to actually
being a real part of the Kling project
itself so the the kernel that we worked
on at CERN is now actually part of clang
so if you install you know LVM and clang
and clang then you actually get a
jupiter kernel for doing interactive c++
in the notebook and now Thomas is gonna
take over and do some demonstrations of
notebooks in the variety of languages
all right demo time
say min mentioned the most of the
variety of kernels are written by people
out there in the community who are using
whatever language and not by us but you
know we we also use other languages and
we do have some role in some of the
other kernels like the clean kernel that
men initially wrote and so it's some of
those that I'm primarily going to be
demonstrating here
so first off I'm going to start with the
our kernel so this is this is a native
kernel it's a first class kernel
completely written in our and you know
you can run some simple our code and
here where you've where I'm displaying
an our data frame you can see that it's
producing the rich representation HTML
output and similarly if I do a plot then
it creates the that's doing using a PNG
representation to put it into the into
the notebook and the plotting can also
do other formats and one of the kind of
one of the challenges with writing other
kernels and using this display machinery
is that the Gupta protocol defines how
you actually send these different
formats over the wire but it doesn't it
doesn't do anything to it doesn't say
anything about like how that is
integrated into the language in
different ways so python has this notion
of this special method double underscore
wrapper and we kind of extended that in
Python so you have like wrapper HTML
wrapper PNG and whatever and we look for
those methods to decide what we can
display in our things are doesn't have a
direct equivalent of that mechanism but
we've written as part of the our kernel
of the library for are called wrapper
which defines so R has these these kind
of generic methods so we've defined a
generic reparation ml method and then
anyone can implement so for example here
the wrapper HTML data frame we had a bit
bigger that's the that's the method that
is used to display that HTML data frame
and these can be so wrapper defines
these methods for a bunch of a bunch of
common classes like data frames and
plots if you're writing in our package
you can also include the implementations
of these with with your code and if
you're using an r package and you want
to you want to integrate it better with
the notebook and you know it's not
something that the authors of that
package have supported or refere at self
has supported then you can define define
that generic method for for that type
and it will work so bash is another
thing that have I've worked on so this
is right at the other end of the
spectrum this is a replica kernel so
it's running here a back in the the
kernel process that the notebook is
communicating with is a Python process
and then that is running yet another
process which is a bash a bash terminal
running in the a PTY a serial terminal
so I I think this won't work on Windows
because it requires UNIX II features but
then you don't have to use bash on
Windows anyway so you can do all of the
things that that we do in you do in bash
and this is just to highlight that so
normally when you do a man command it
would show up in the pager and so part
of what the kernel does is to make to
make bash fit better into this
it sets the pager to cat ritual just
past VM past the input through to the
output without any change and so rather
than rather than trying to startup less
which would get the kernel into horrible
mess I went round the less command here
because it will break things and it just
pipes things like that through to the
terminal and you can also do things that
wait
they probably shouldn't have made that
wait so long there we go and then Osman
mentioned there's a display function so
you can pipe an image into this display
function and it saves it off to a
temporary file somewhere and then sends
through stood out this like special
special token to say like there's an
image to display and it's in this file
so that's kind of like a different
another take on like you saw the HTML
generic method for for our bashes
equivalent is like a a bash function
that you can pipe data into so here's a
a Julie our example julia is other than
ipython it is the most complete kernel
and that extends as far as julia
implements widgets so you can use this
julia package called interact let's just
make this a little bit bigger and here
I've got some sliders and as I drag them
around the color of this bit of text
will change and similarly I can draw a
plot like this and as I move the slider
it will in a moment
hopefully cursive doing live demos okay
well maybe that's not going to work
today it should update live anyway we
can't have everything work when I'm
doing a live demo so that's kind of the
the Jupiter take on multi-language
support as you have like each each
notebook associated with a kernel which
usually means a particular language but
as Minh was saying like the the kernel
can do anything at once with the the
text that it's getting from the front
end that represents usually some kind of
code and so there's no reason that you
can't build multi-language support in at
the kernel level as well and indeed this
is part of what we do with ipython
and various various projects exist to
support this so this is I just
so this is our integration with NI
pythons I have a Python notebook here
and using our PI 2 which is a Python our
interoperability library I can start a
cell with this percent percent our cell
magic and then all of the code within
that cell is treated as R and this is
actually so we have a variety of these
magics some of them run inside some of
them run the code in a different process
so it has no no real communications with
the the Python kernel the r1 goes a bit
further so it's loading our and running
the code in the same process as Python
so we can do things like if we've got
this is a panda's data frame with this
is data from Yahoo Finance for the
Google's stock then if we do an R cell
magic with this data ie for input DF
command that takes the the panda's data
frame and it works for other other kinds
of thing as well and transforms it into
our so that's now in our data frame and
you can do operations with it so here's
a and this is just building a simple
regression model to see of the the
change in stock price over a day is
related to the amount of that stock that
was traded or something like you can
tell I'm not a finance person but yeah
that you can you can move your data very
quickly and easily from - into R and so
you can you can do like your input in
preparation steps in Python for instance
and then move it into our to do some
statistical test that may not be
implemented in Python
so yeah this is this is that kind of
thing so there are for a whole variety
of languages just about any any sort of
scripting language that can take code on
standard in and run it we can we have or
we can easily have a cell magic that
will just start that process start left
interpreter in a separate process and
throw the code into it which is I mean
that's kind of the the magic equivalent
of a raffle wrapper kernel it's very
very quick and easy to do but very
limited and what you can do with it
there are are and Giulio magics that
load the relevant interpreter in the
same process and that lets you pass data
back and forth and there's a cycle in
magic which we'll use cyclin to compile
a function that you define and then you
load it directly onto your namespace you
can define a cyclin function in one cell
and call it from - in the next C are
some of the some of the challenges that
we've encountered in this I mentioned
the different different kinds of rich
display mechanisms and how that fits
into each language getting good 0 mq
bindings for each language can be tricky
so mins min maintains the 0 au 0 mq
bindings for python and does so very
well and they're very reliable but the
cerium q bindings for R for example are
not so reliable and it's been a major
source of problems for the our kernel is
making that work well so that's a factor
that weighs in favor of doing wrapper
kernels rather than native kernels is
native kernel you have to have a 0 mq
library in whatever language and
capturing output live so a lot of the
kernels like the bash kernel for
instance at the moment it will when you
run something it will you won't see
anything until that SL has completely
finished running and then it will
give you all the outputs one block and
doing that getting the output live is
more of a challenge I'm gonna just get
over that because we're short on time I
want to get to the feature previews of
new and upcoming stuff and so I'm going
to demo one thing and then Minh's going
to come back on for the finale so I've
been working recently on going back to
the terminal
so the in development version of ipython
and the jupiter console which is our
terminal front end for Jupiter Jupiter
kernels and we've moved away from the
Red Line library which we were using for
terminal interaction and tab-completion
and things to a library called prompt
toolkit which means that I don't know
how visible this will be on the
projector but you can see that there so
we now have syntax highlighting
happening live in the terminal and also
things like proper multi-line editing I
can go up and down between lines here
thank you
if you're interested in that come and
find me afterwards to talk more about it
but now I'll hand back over to min to
demonstrate one or two other new things
before we have to go yeah so another
thing that we're working on for the 5.0
release of Jupiter source for being
careful if he did a demo from a stable
version and I get to run for master so
one of the things we're working on is
refactoring all of the Java scripts
we've accumulated a bunch of Java Script
over the past several years that is
let's say less than optimal and we're in
the midst of rewriting the the
JavaScript side of a lot of the Jupiter
stuff with more more modern practices
and so we've got a bit of a neat
you you I for for doing these things and
I can look at a nice little file browser
I can open an image that SVG's don't
work but I can look at notebooks and
then these can be paneled and laid out
and we've got a I can open a terminal
and run my Python over here and open a
new text file
I'll bring my text file over to this
panel
and I've got a foreign keyboard
what what's the folder no I am right so
I've got you know normal side by side
terminal and and things and you can
bring up bring up help in a side tab for
this is on NB viewer and collapse that
and then so that's Jupiter lab that
we've got coming and it's very rough but
it's rapidly rapidly getting nicer and
then the last bit is in agar
old-fashioned notebook we've got a mark
down cell and I want let's say I want to
put an image in there but maybe I don't
want to do it by a URL I just want to
maybe grab that image and just drag it
over there and then just drag images
from your file system and they're
embedded in the
and this attachments thing this is a
cool thing was I believe the person put
together was their first contribution to
Jupiter for for anything and he's put
together a nice description of updates
to the document format specification and
then the implementation of the
JavaScript yeah
so I for one would just like to mention
I'm excited about all this and I can
imagine many of you are would anyone
have any questions cities to find
gentlemen who are working on this
amazing amazing amazing project where do
I find the stupider lab it's in the the
notebook repo and master a few things
install notebook from master they'll get
the silly button on there for try to
keep your lab any other questions
we're running from my laptop and I don't
have it set up
yeah installing Kling is a challenge
because you need like latest versions of
LLVM latest versions of clang well we
should emphasize installing clean from
the development version yeah that's true
is there hasn't been a release of cling
since this was at it if you when there's
stable releases you can just grab a
binary and it's fine but the the kernel
hasn't made it into a stable release yet
so you need to get it from master and
that can be challenging
so I was wondering how much of a penalty
is there when you go from a positive
frame for example to an our data frame
is there like an internal copy or how
does it work there is an internal coffee
so it doesn't it's it doesn't have to
like dump it all to a CSV file and then
read it back or something it's it's
quicker than that
but yeah there is a there is an
in-memory copy so it's you know moving
moving data around and rearranging it in
two hours format and that's that's
another thing like I think our Page who
is now responsible for that there was at
one point both our PI 2 and pandas had
separate implementations of that
conversion but I think it's I think it's
our PI twos that's now used yeah and I
think that's that's one thing that when
you're talking to Julia as opposed to
our julia has an easier time talking
natively to an enum PI data layout so
you can you can have shared shared
memory between Python and Julia much
more easily than you can with Python and
our I'm not sure can you share an array
yeah I think I think I think you can
share a data frame yeah I think so I
think an array can work without copying
but in that case I might have one more
question so there's a separate package
for communicating between R and Python
is there such a thing necessary for
Julia because Julie has an easy time
importing some of the pipe and stuff but
pushing stuff from Julia to - something
yes so there's two packages one of which
is very active and well maintained and
that's PI call that's for calling Python
from Julia the other is the other
direction which is PI giulio just for
calling Julia from Python and we learned
while putting together demos yesterday
that that is not super well maintained
but it's in in principle and and I don't
know I don't know exactly the details of
that but
so the library exists it's in it's in a
little bit of disrepair as Julia's moved
on you know kind of moved out from under
it a little bit but it's it's a small
library so maintaining it should if
people are interested in it should
should be able to catch it back up then
considering there are no more questions
can we get like two good rounds of
apologies this is an amazing project and
we are super happy that we've had you